[Música]
imagínense una chavita ok viviendo aquí
en el 2018 regia y está soltera
iba a ser conquistada por dos galanes
región verdad sin embargo
ellos van a estar a distancia de ella y
pues se tienen que dar el labor de
conquistarla
ahora aquí está el truco uno de ellos no
mal no va a poder hacer con las
herramientas y las tecnologías que había
en la época medieval imagínense no sé
que nuestro uso robin hood verdad
el otro milenio como ustedes como todos
nosotros vamos a aprovechar las
tecnologías herramientas que hay ahorita
quién creen de ustedes que la va a
conquistar primero
pues mira se lo voy a hacer corto el
joven es el medieval pues que tendría
que hacer verdad ir por un papel
sentarse en su escritorio prender una
vela
agarrar un palito ponerle tinta verdad
escribir
y luego usar esa cera para hacer una
estampa no sé dónde iba a ir a agarrar
una paloma mensajera y enviársela a la
chava verdad
imagínate el otro al momento al instante
a lo mejor él hubiera escogido que
facebook para empezar la checa su nombre
sabe con quién se junta que hace
se puede mudar a instagram y si se
quiere un poco conservador pues le da un
falo y empezó a jugar el rey
se puede ir un poquito más agresivo
mandarle un mensaje o comentarle en un
stories verdad
además de eso que ya la contacto ya
empezó en liga el coqueteo
tiene una cantidad de información mucho
superior a la otra y perdona la
redundancia porque si la tiene muy mucha
ventaja sobre el otro
o sea todo lo que aprendió de esta chava
ahora ya sabe si escriba chipinque o es
de esas que va a calzada con su perrito
verdad
o de las que leen su hamaca tomando té o
de esas que ven netflix con su cobija
así te quita
o son de las que se levantan al buen
despertar y se toman su jugo con piñas y
espinacas de ahora o pues ya de plano si
se va directo a las mimosas
bueno
así quién crees que ganaría y la
conquistaría primero por mira es muy
evidente el milenio
la tecnología
y estas herramientas han cambiado a
través de la historia y toda historia
siempre ha habido este revoluciones
industriales que han cambiado las formas
de vivir las formas de interactuar es
más lo va a poner muy sencillo
imagínense siguen en los tiempos
medievales pues había un herrero verdad
ese reloj tenía su fierro agarrar su
perrito lo pone en carbón y luego
empezaba a hacer dos espadas y se la
vendía a no sé quién a sus familiares o
al rey que estaba en ese entonces
luego en la industria 1.0 en la primera
revolución industrial
lo que pasó es que empezaron a ver
máquinas máquinas que ya no las tenían
que mover personas ni animales
ya podían extraer recursos naturales
como petróleo hierro cobre algodón
textiles de una manera más rápido
entonces ya había más materia prima
entonces necesitaba ver gente que podría
procesar esa materia prima de una manera
más rápida entonces empezaron a ver pues
más máquinas verdad y más máquinas y más
gente que compre cosas hay más empleos
entonces se movió de gente de comunidad
a gente de ciudad
luego en la 2.0 en la segunda revolución
industrial que creen que puso la
electricidad
la electricidad cambió radicalmente las
formas de trabajar
ya pues en mi ford con su línea de
ensamblaje pudo hacer más carros
ya podrías poner máquinas en más partes
ya podías tener refrigeradores luz
ya no necesitas vivir más en el día ya
podías vivir de noche ya podrías ir al
cine a fiestas ya podías conducir habían
luz ya no necesariamente necesitamos
vivir en el día y esto cambia los modos
y formas de socializar
entonces luego hace poco en los 1970 60s
empieza lo que es la automatización con
novatos verdad esto también cambió
radicalmente porque ya todos podríamos
tener más tecnologías a un costo muy
barato ya había más computadoras
más celulares para todos
y ahorita precisamente estamos en una
transición de la 3.0 a la 4.0 lo que
ahora le llaman la era de digitalización
verdad
en esta era pues ya están habiendo
cambios así como el milenio el este pues
le puso una friega al otro pobre que
tenía las herramientas del medievalismo
y así ha pasado con todo lo que nosotros
estamos haciendo
y hay una forma muy muy muy sencilla de
hacerlo
pero si está en debate muchos me podrán
argumentar que no pero es quitándonos el
papel
y si quitamos el papel
qué es quitarnos el papel libretas
libros
efectivo casa
y documentación
todo eso ya hay otras cosas mejores
verdad
si nos quedamos con todavía con esa
mentalidad no vamos a poder dar el paso
en esta sociedad que está media dividida
hay gente que vive todavía con
tecnologías de la 3.0 y otros que tengan
la 4.0 y no vamos a poder progresar
rápido a esta nueva era si no nos
quitamos el papel
sino que las organizaciones ya han
sufrido ese tipo de efectos que dijo
walmart cuando le empezaron a quitar
este un segmento de que le compraban
libros amazon
qué dijeron esos taxistas esa industria
vieja que hay alguien me va a quitar
mucha mano y ver
lo que dijo el blockbuster cuando una
plataforma que va a vender movies de
forma digital
netflix
eso nos puede pasar a nosotros sí nos
digitalizamos si no dejamos de usar ese
papel yo sé y cuando yo platico de esto
me dicen es que el libro me huele a
viejo y es un sentimiento que yo tengo
poner verdad
si está bien pero pueden tener toda una
biblioteca en una tableta y es mucho más
rápido encontrar los libros si no te
sabes una palabra directamente en la
puedes checar verdad ya no necesitas
muchos libros en los que tengas que
investigar o leer además de que ese
espacio cuanto ahorita que el metro
cuadrado está muy caro pues tú quieres
espacio
ahora también hay gente que me dice es
que yo no aprendo si no tomo notas si no
lo escribo a puño y letra' verdad típica
es la más típica estás especialmente me
ama
y claro pero fíjense cuánto tiempo se la
pasan texteando taipé ando viendo
computadora viendo plataformas digitales
vídeos imagínense que esas notas ustedes
las tuvieran por el resto de su vida
osea yo ahorita que estoy trabajando en
una planta química me encantaría poder
tener a la mano todo lo que aprendí en
mis clases en carrera lo más que me
tengo que quién sabe alegría los tiraron
entonces todo ese aprendizaje puede
estar de otra forma entonces eso va a
cambiar la forma que nosotros hacemos
las cosas
y es bien
importante nosotros hacer este paso como
sociedad porque no lo podemos hacer
solos no podemos hacerlo más los jóvenes
los adultos también se tienen que
adaptar hay otros que están entre que sí
que no
pero si no nos van a pasar como estos
grandes empresas
yo no creo que hayan dicho sabes que
para que tengo luz o focos en mi casa
verdad
no tampoco creo que hayan dicho hay para
que quiero un celular o una computadora
sí ahí está el teléfono de mi casa
entonces así como va a cambiar esto que
estamos apenas entrando a la 4.0 a la
época de digitalización
entonces tenemos que quitarnos el papel
si van a usar el papel de nuevo pónganse
en el papel de ese milenio
y se los juro
que conquistarán primero muchas
[Aplausos]